thanks to dashlane for keeping legal
eagle in the air I'm gonna make this
pencil disappear cute magic trick also
first-degree murder hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a lawyer welcome
back to laws broken where an attorney
destroys your favorite childhood movies
by showing you how illegal everything is
because everything is illegal this week
we're going to examine the Dark Knight
and we're finally going to answer the
question can Batman use the self-defence
justification can you trust me do you
trust him of course you can trust me I'm
an attorney as most people know the
Batman stories take place in the
fictional city of Gotham but as everyone
recognizes Gotham is just a stand-in for
New York City and since I am licensed to
practice in the state of New York I'm
going to be using New York law for the
most part to talk about the various
crimes of the Joker and Batman so be
sure to subscribe and comment in the
form of an objection which all either
sustain or overrule and stick around
until the end of the video where I give
a verdict for how long the Joker and
Batman are both going to jail so let's
examine the evidence
all right so we have your standard
garden-variety Breaking and Entering and
criminal trespass on to the building of
a bank three of a kind let's do this
I see three guys two guys on the roof
every guy gets a share five shares is
plenty six years
don't forget the guy playing the job he
thinks you can sit it out and still take
a slice I know what they call them the
Joker okay so these bad guys have
helpfully explained that they are all
engaged in a criminal conspiracy to rob
a bank as members of a conspiracy
assuming that the Pinkerton doctrine
applies all of the members of the
conspiracy including the Joker are on
the hook for all of the criminal acts of
their co-conspirators so I'm going to
impugn all the bank robbers bad acts -
the Joker himself
that's gonna dial out to 911 when I was
trying to reach a private number is it a
problem no I'm done good and that's just
straight-up murder but because all of
these bank robbers are engaged in a
conspiracy to conduct an inherently
dangerous crime that's armed robbery
with guns and bombs and grenades all of
those co-conspirators are likely on the
hook for the murder of this person under
the felony murder rule but on top of
that the felony murder rule would apply
to any unintentional killings that occur
during the course of this armed robbery
as well all right William Fichtner
bringing the heat
so the bank manager comes out with guns
blazing you might assume that this is
attempted murder because he's using a
shotgun to try and kill the bank robbers
but it's likely that the justification
of self-defense applies here and excuses
his actions we're gonna be talking a lot
about the justification of self-defense
in a moment but to give you a preview
robbery is one of the enumerated
categories of situations where you're
allowed to use deadly force to protect
against it so I think the bank manager
is probably justified in using deadly
force to protect against the robbery of
the Joker at his henchmen and because
the Joker is not justified in using
deadly force that's just plain old
attempted murder boss told me when the
guy was done I should take him out no no
more murder I'm betting the Joker told
you to kill me soon as we loaded the
cash driver
what was driving obviously this is some
type of murder here but what's going on
well the Joker knew that the bus was
going to break through the wall at a
certain time so one might argue that
because he didn't intentionally pull a
trigger and shoot a gun that he's not
liable for first-degree murder the
problem is that because he knew this was
going to happen and moved out of the way
and force the guy into the path of the
bus that as a mental state we call
knowingly which generally carries with
it exactly the same kind of penalty that
you would have when you intentionally do
an act that results in someone's death
so in this case even though the Joker
didn't pull the trigger he knowingly
engaged in actions that would lead to
the death of his co-conspirator which
would qualify as at least second-degree
murder if not first-degree murder and
that's just your garden-variety form of
murder
so the Joker made physical contact with
the bank manager there which technically
qualifies as assault and because he used
a smoke bomb instead of an actual
incendiary grenade I think that would
probably qualify as intentional
infliction of emotional distress even
though the man was not physically harmed
in the explosion from a grenade
destruction of property
[Music]
don't let me find you out here again
we're trying to help you I don't need
help not my diagnosis what gives you the
right what's the difference between you
and me not much
is Batman justified in using
self-defense and patrolling the streets
of Gotham well let's think like a lawyer
[Music]
the state of New York recognizes
self-defense as a justification for
using physical force in the defense of
different people whether it applies is
complicated now the rules of using
physical force and deadly physical force
are different generally speaking you're
allowed to use physical force in
self-defense if you believe it is
reasonably necessary to defend yourself
or a third person against the imminent
use of unlawful physical force of course
there are exceptions to that you're not
justified in using physical force when
your conduct is the one that provoked
the actor who is going to use physical
force against you you can't use physical
force if you were the initial aggressor
unless you have clearly withdrawn from
the encounter and communicated that you
have withdrawn and the second person has
continued to attack you now the rules of
using deadly force are even more strict
than using just physical force you are
not allowed to use deadly force unless
you reasonably believe that the other
aggressor is in fact going to use deadly
force against you and that is your
option to prevent it being used against
yourself
but even there if you have the
opportunity to avoid the situation
entirely and retreat to safety you have
an obligation to do so before engaging
in deadly force however you don't have a
duty to withdraw if you are one in your
own home or to you reasonably believe
that another person is attempting to
commit a burglary or you believe that
the aggressive third party who is about
to use deadly force is going to commit a
kidnapping a forcible rape a forcible
criminal sexual assault or a robbery
under those specific enumerated
situations you don't have a duty to
retreat how do we deal with Batman well
number one I don't think Batman is ever
using regular physical force he has been
trained as basically a ninja while he
has a code that says he shouldn't kill
someone
he has the kind of training that makes
his actions I think deadly and even
though he doesn't try to kill people I
think it's clear that people die when he
gets involved we can disagree about
whether his acts are on balance good for
the city but the fact of the matter is
they are illegal at least under New York
law New York law does not look kindly on
vigilantes you can't just interject
yourself into crime and and pretend to
be police it just doesn't work that way
he would likely be on the hook as guilty
for all of the hundreds of acts of
physical assault that he has committed
against the criminals of Gotham cute
magic trick also first-degree murder
all right threatening everyone with a
jacket full of grenades that's what we
call a true threat sometimes you run
into First Amendment issues and whether
you're allowed to say things to certain
people that's clearly not allowed here
where you have what are presumably real
grenades and threatening people with
them why so serious
alright so there's some regular murder
our operation is small but there's a lot
of potential for aggressive expansion so
which of you fine gentlemen would like
to join our team oh there's only one
spot open right now so we're gonna have
tryouts arguably you could say that
those people engaged in physical
violence because of the duress from the
Joker so I think the Joker is probably
on the hook for two more counts of
homicide
[Music]
I'm not sure what the equivalent of the
FAA would be in Hong Kong but you're not
allowed to go gliding around a city like
that that would be a violation of
airspace at least in New York City I'm
assuming Hong Kong probably has a
similar thing so when people go BASE
jumping off of buildings totally illegal
reckless endangerment and some sort of
violation of aviation law
and their Batman just straight-up
kidnapped Slough whatever the Hong Kong
equivalent of kidnapping I think that's
probably what Batman just engaged in
Batman drops off Lau to lieutenant
Gordon so the question is can the police
actually use evidence that they get from
Lau because Batman illegally kidnapped
him from an international country well
there is a doctrine that applies to
governments that says if the evidence is
wrongfully obtained and you use that
wrongfully obtained evidence to find
more evidence down the line that's
called the fruit of the poisonous tree
and often that is excluded at trial but
the thing is Batman is not a police
officer Batman is a private party
so while Batman may be liable and almost
certainly is liable for the use of
deadly force and for illegal kidnapping
the fruit of the poisonous tree doctrine
doesn't apply because the police here
were blameless does they get anything on
you and those criminals are back on the
streets followed swiftly by you and me
all right
another act of murder by the Joker
killing the Batman like vigilante you
see this is how crazy Batman's made
Gotham order in Gotham Batman must take
off his mask and turn himself in every
day he doesn't people will die
starting tonight I'm a man of my word
all right so the Joker there not only is
he engaging an assault and homicide
against this vigilante Batman wannabe
but he's also engaging in a terroristic
threat against the government and people
of Gotham itself under new york penal
code section 490 a person is guilty of
terrorism when they intimidate or coerce
a civilian population influence the
policy of a unit of government by
intimidation or coercion or affect the
conduct of a unit of government by
murder assassination kidnapping etc here
the Joker is engaging in all of that
he's trying to get the police to stop
working he's trying to get Batman to
stop chasing him and he is trying to
terrorize the entire civilian population
into disclosing the identity of
and to turn against Batman so I think
that as a classic case of terrorism of
mass terror and making a terroristic
threat alright
murder of the judge murder of the police
chief
and technically Bruce Wayne has engaged
in kidnapping of Harvey Dent by taking
Harvey Dent away from the party against
his will little fighting you I like that
again because Batman doesn't have these
justification of self-defense he is not
legally allowed to commit these acts of
assault and battery even against the
Joker's henchmen here he had a duty to
withdraw because he didn't he's likely
guilty of several dozen counts of
battery drop the gun oh sure you just
take off your little mask and show us
all who you really are okay here we have
a clear loitering violation in addition
to the normal things that constitute
loitering a person loiters when he or
she is masked or disguised in an
unnatural way or attire and remains or
congregates in public so clearly Batman
is violating the law during statute here
very poor choice of words
[Music]
I still don't fully understand how
Batman and Rachel survived that fall but
nonetheless still an attempted murder by
the Joker and I think that probably
constitutes the unpermitted use of
indoor pyrotechnics or firearms which is
a Class E felony in New York even for
the purposes of wannabe detective work
and obviously Batman is gonna beat the
crap out of some of these bodyguards
still counts as breaking and entering
even though Liao's guards are using
deadly force against Batman that
probably doesn't give him justification
for him to use deadly force or close to
deadly force against them he has a duty
to withdraw not breaking into the
building for the purpose of arresting
these people from one professional to
another all right so obviously Batman is
engaging in assault and battery against
this mobster New York does not have a
specific offense called
torture that would just simply fall
under the regular rubric of battery and
assault and it would simply be enhanced
based on all of the factors that went
into it the Batman's you know ferocity
with which she beat the crap out of this
mobster for the purpose of information
California on the other hand does have a
specific crime called torture which is
found when an individual inflict great
bodily injury with the intent to cause
cruel or extreme pain for the purposes
of revenge
extortion persuasion or sadism so the
end result here would be probably
exactly the same I just find it
particularly interesting that one state
has an actual offense called torture
while New York does not
[Music]
all right using cars and trucks as a
deadly weapon clearly qualifies as
aggravated vehicular assault and
attempted aggravated vehicular homicide
when you attack a police officer it
almost always enhances the crime which
carries within a very very severe
penalty all right Batman is driving his
bat-cycle around Gotham destroying lots
of different cars probably guilty of
reckless endangerment of property
someone is guilty of reckless
endangerment of property when they
engage in reckless conduct which creates
a substantial risk to damaging the
property of other people here Batman is
driving a motorcycle which is not
licensed which's in no way street legal
and is just destroying cars left and
right
all right so in addition to all of the
dozens or so aggravated murders that the
Joker has done by killing a bunch of
police officers he has also engaged in a
violation of section 195 a penal code
which is to obstruct a government
function by use of a bomb there is a
specific provision that prevents you
from using or threatening to use a bomb
against the government it definitely
applies there if Coleman Reese isn't
dead in 60 minutes then I blow up so in
addition to aiding and abetting the
homicide of this person who was going to
damask Batman it also probably qualifies
as criminal Anarchy and inciting to riot
under Section 240 of the New York Penal
Code the the Joker is just trying to
create pandemonium and there are rules
against doing that not surprisingly
beautiful
unethical dangerous we've turned every
cellphone and Gotham into a microphone
and a high frequency generator receiver
you took my sonar concept and applied it
to every phone in the city
half the city feeling you saw naught you
can image all of Gotham this is wrong
all right Lucius Fox is a hundred
percent right that everything Batman is
doing here is inappropriate constitutes
a number of different computer crimes
under Section 156 of a New York Penal
Code including the unauthorized use of a
computer computer trespass computer
tampering wiretapping invasion of
privacy there is really no end to how
illegal this particular tactic of Batman
is basically by hacking everyone's
phones he just engaged in 30 million
different felony computer crimes at
midnight I blow you all up however
so who's it gonna be Harvey Dent's
most-wanted scumbag collection or the
sweet innocent civilians you choose all
right so obviously this probably
constitutes a number of attempted
homicides but I think it also probably
constitutes rioting or incitement to
riot under Section 240 of the New York
Penal Code all right
that's the Dark Knight Batman and the
Joker giving each other a run for their
money in terms of who can commit the
most number of crimes but now it's time
for a verdict how long are they going to
jail we'll start with the Joker there
are a lot of crimes so many crimes
murder murder straight-up murder murder
I won't beat a dead horse but murder
murder why there's so many crimes I'm
going to have to combine different
crimes into buckets here in the assault
bucket which includes aggravated
vehicular assault the Joker engaged in
approximately 65 counts each carrying a
penalty of 3 to 15 years in prison given
the violence and severity of the crimes
I'll assume that he would get the
maximum sentence for each for a total of
nine hundred and seventy five years now
given all the people on the ferries the
Joker committed approximately 400 counts
of attempted murder at 25 years each
that's 10,000 years in jail
five counts of terrorism and criminal
anarchy for 125 years in jail 35 counts
of first degree felony and aggravated
murder for 35 life sentences so if all
of these sentences ran concurrently the
Joker would serve approximately 35 life
sentences and 12,000 years in jail how
long my phone call now let's talk about
Batman
assuming self-defense doesn't apply
which it probably doesn't and assuming
the sentences run concurrently Batman
assaulted approximately 50 henchmen
bodyguards and regular people for
conservatively a hundred and fifty years
in jail a destruction of property
kidnapping and torture for approximately
forty five years in jail and of course
30 million counts of computer trespass
and tampering and wiretapping for
roughly 60 million years in jail huh
that is a long time in Arkham
see yourself I know Batman is supposed
to be the good guy but I was really
creeped out when he hacked everyone's
phones unethical dangerous the people of
Gotham really could have used - lame -
lame protects your identity across the
internet by providing a tool to generate
strong passwords stores and auto fills
them securely everywhere on the Internet
seamlessly across all of your devices
even across laptops and mobile devices
running different operating systems and
different browsers so even Batman can't
steal your password it's also a VPN
which acts as an intermediary to make
sure that all of your internet traffic
is encrypted even when you're on public
Wi-Fi try - lame free for 30-days at the
link below legal eagles will get 10% off
of - lame premium by using the promo
code at checkout so click on the link
and prevent hacks because the Batman's
and Joker's of the world are out there
you're a garbage do you agree leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist I put together that
includes all of my other laws broken
videos so click on the playlist and I'll
see you in court